the story of Han Solo has finally been
told from the illicit way he got his
ship to the accidental way he got his
name solo a Star Wars story has
everything you've ever wanted to know
about the galaxy's most famous ruffian
with a heart of gold the conclusion of
solo comes down to a world of double
crosses with secret agendas being
revealed and hard-won loyalties being
betrayed Horne comes out on top in the
end of course but things get a little
dicey for him and his friends before the
credits roll tantalizing story threads
are left dangling with some surprising
appearances hinting a more story to come
it's a lot to take in all at once
luckily we've got some tricks up our
sleeve to help even the scruffy-looking
nerf-herder
make sense of it all in short you're
clear kid let's explain the ending to
this thing and go home
trust no one after accomplishing of time
and space bending escaped through the
dangerous Maelstrom Han and company make
their way back to the yacht headquarters
of gangster dryden vas their goal is to
deliver a supply of refined Co axiom to
vas Co axiom being a valuable fuel
source that can also serve as a powerful
explosive before delivering the goods to
vas Han and Friends make noise of the
Marauder and fists nest who and masks
herself to reveal that she's a teenage
girl fighting on behalf of a nascent
rebellion Co axiom Powell's the universe
and she's been trying to acquire the co
axiom for the cloud riders
anti-establishment goals something about
the arrangement speaks to Hans
rebellious streak so the smuggler
hatches a plan to let ness to keep the
goods but Hans plant experiences
complications when it's revealed that
his partner Beckett has been in league
with vas the whole time after warning
Hahn throughout the movie to trust no
one
he finally demonstrates why with his
ultimate betrayal leaving with the Co
axiom and Chewbacca
there is another after Hans clever plan
devolves into a gunfight that leaves
Voss and his men done for Han goes off
in search of Chewbacca while Kyra stays
behind advices yachts Kira hails a
mysterious hooded figure it turns out to
be someone many Star Wars fans figured
they would never see in the movies again
prequel villain Darth Maul improbably
back from an early demise to head up the
crime organization crimson dawn a lot
has changed since the last time we saw
this devilish foe who was literally cut
in half where obi-wan Kenobi
at the end of the Phantom Menace left in
pieces at the bottom of a massive piece
more survived through sheer force of
well and later thrived with the help of
some powerful robot legs this is a more
that's older angrier and more dangerous
than ever before more Lourdes Kiera to
come visit him on his homeworld of
Dathomir Kiera obliges leaving han and
chewbacca behind on the planet
more like NFS best after Chewbacca and
Han Solo reunite the kind-hearted
bandits drugged their quarry of CO axiom
back to the camp of the cloud riders and
former foil and fists nest initially
this big reveal around nest is that this
big bad space Marauder is actually a
young girl but the more interesting
twists occurs as it becomes clear she's
one of the Warriors who helped to spark
the Galactic rebellion her final parting
words to Han indicates her belief that
he'll find a way to the rebellion one
day two solo shows harm rebelling
against the Empire for selfish reasons
but the original trilogy sees him
becoming a rebel for the sake of others
not just himself interestingly nest is
so young that she could conceivably
still be alive in the time of episode 9
sheer Disney and Lucasfilm feel like
going there her scariest nest is for the
first chunk of solo she really doesn't
get to do much once she reveals her true
colors but it's a wide galaxy and it's a
big franchise if she proves to be a fan
favorite there's plenty of room for her
to pop up somewhere give me the prize
after Hans crew is paired down to just
him and Chewbacca the two made their way
to a new planet to catch up with Lando
and tie up one last loose end
Barna greets lunda with a move that will
look familiar to fans of the Empire
Strikes Back throwing him off for the
threat of a punch before yanking him
gruffly into a woman brace
well the gesture seemed to be a
spontaneous show of affection in its
first appearance here the move is
deployed with purpose while they're in
close contact hard deftly picks Lando's
pockets or rather his taxi-driver style
wrist holster pilfering the extra cards
he used to cheat the first time they
played sub arc Hans dishonorable
vengeance allows him to finally win the
Millennium Falcon in a card game bet
becoming the ship's sole owner of
through the events of Return of the Jedi
curiously Han appears to take the
Millennium Falcon well after l33 sevens
mine has been uploaded to the ship's
interface and there's no indication that
he ever unplugs her from the ship and
gives her back to Lando
the implications are haunting not only
does Han cheetah's wait liberating Lando
from his beloved ship and home he also
appears to steal his best friend along
with it
though turned him over to Darth Vader a
very big gangster in the final moments
of the movie han and chewie prepare for
a trip to Tatooine to meet a very big
gangster and though gangster in the
galaxy seems to be bigger or more
grotesque than Jabba the Hutt why were
you always like to see puppets and Star
Wars movies that Jabba puppet is a real
headache to operate if you want the
character to be mobile maybe in the next
one if there is a next one we'll see the
space slug get off his butt little after
all CGI has come a long way since 97
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff you
know you're lifting
[Music]